this title I didn't really realize I'd
be at
speaking to an audience that actually
included witches and wizards so
yeah well I'll probably I'll probably
meet them in question period that'd be
my guess
so can you all hear me
one of you can't hear me
how's that
that's better okay all right good
all right so
as you can plainly see the title of this
talk is dragons Divine parents Heroes
and adversaries a complete cosmology of
being
sounds dreadfully new age to me
but it's not
um
new age people are very creative but
they can't think critically
but I can think critically
so this is a creative
theoretical Enterprise
conjoined with the capacity to tell the
difference between bad ideas and good
ideas
and hopefully what I'm going to talk to
you about are the greatest ideas that
Humanity has ever produced
there are also ideas that we're
we don't understand well
and
whose highest level of formal
development
we risk forgetting because uh
we're criticizing things that we
we invent it as a species but that we
cannot understand rationally and
we're predisposed to believe that
ideas that we can't understand
rationally have to be wrong and
sometimes that's true but sometimes
we're just not smart enough to
understand them
so
I can give you an example of something
that we're not really smart enough to
understand
we're not really smart enough to
understand why people would line up for
four nights for ten blocks to watch Star
Wars
you know I mean they won't do that for a
lecture
and they wouldn't pay money
and so you know the Star Wars for
example is naturally
it's naturally interesting
and people just take that for granted
but the fact that people will line up
to it to engage voluntary voluntarily in
a ritual activity of that sort
is a manifestation of something that's
very deep in the human psyche that we do
not comprehend well
so I'm going to talk to you about
what I like to think of is the grammar
of belief
I got interested in this back in the mid
80s
my was driven mostly by an interest in
Global Warfare that was ideologically
motivated and also atrocity
Warfare was not so difficult to
understand in some sense because you can
map it onto
animal territoriality
but atrocity in the service of ideology
is a whole different thing
that's certainly clear that for example
in World War II
when the Nazis had to make a choice
perhaps between winning the war and
accelerating the rate at which they were
killing Jews they chose the latter
and it's very difficult to understand
that using a model based on animal
territoriality
I started reading about
belief systems widely in
in political writings and economic
writings and religious writings and
psychological writings anywhere I could
find a thread that I thought was
promising
I read a lot of Jung I read a lot of
Freud almost all the great clinical
psychologists a lot of soldier knits and
a lot of George Orwell
they're all people a lot of Dostoevsky
and Nietzsche they're all people who as
far as I could tell had something very
original to say
and
out of that
I learned to understand why people need
belief why it's actually inevitable
why faith and faith is inevitable faith
is inevitable in part because your
knowledge is finite and so you have to
take some things for granted or you fall
into an infinite regress
and what maybe
constituted the difference between
pathological belief and non-pathological
beliefs and those are terms by the way
which I think can be defined technically
which is a
statement that runs contrary to the
presupposition say of moral relativism
I'm definitely not a moral relativist
um I think it constitutes a
I think the motivation for moral
relativism fundamentally is the desire
to abdicate responsibility
even though you can make very strong
intellectual cases for for why moral
relativism is correct
um
the intellectual case and the actual
motivation have nothing to do with one
another however
I've also found out something else which
is quite interesting and I don't know
how much I can touch on it tonight but I
don't think that Newton and Darwin are
commensurate
I think that most modern people are
newtonians not darwinians
and I think that you can understand the
grammar of belief which is religious in
nature
using darwinian principles
but it means that you have to give up
your Newtonian presuppositions and so
I I think I can make that argument
implicitly with what I'm doing as I
progress tonight so the first thing I'm
going to tell you is that
it's necessary for you to look at the
world through a limited frame of
reference
and the reason for that is you're not
very smart
your Consciousness can only handle about
four bits of information per second it's
not very much given that the number of
bits of information coming at you from
the external world are for all practical
purposes infinite you're like Aldous
Huxley suggested your brain seems to be
primarily a reducing agent
your bodies are reducing agent as well
because there are lots of things that
you just can't detect and then the room
that you're sitting in is a reducing
agent because it's keeping all sorts of
things out that you would otherwise have
to deal with and the stability of this
city is a reducing agent because we're
not going to be stampeded by barbarians
with any luck at every moment or any
moment
we we deal with the complexity of the
world in part by inhabiting a sequence
of reducing structures
until the world is reduced enough so
that we can actually deal with the
minute elements of it that we can
comprehend at any one moment
and those elements we comprehend
um
are not the familiar objects of
objective reality in fact animals and
people included aren't much interested
in objective reality
um
we're interested in pragmatic reality
pragmatic reality is the reality that
you act on not that you perceive
and because we're embedded in bodies and
because we're biological organisms and
because we're concerned with survival
and reproduction among other things
how to act is a much more important for
much more important question for us than
what is the world constituted of
how to act in some sense is also the
prime darwinian question right because
if you act
wrongly from a darwinian perspective you
end up dead before you can reproduce
so Darwinism
is a pragmatic
theory in fact that pragmatisti the
American pragmatists on the
North American east coast
recognize that
very short period of time after Darwin
studies were published they recognized
the connection between pragmatism as a
theory and darwinian Theory
instantaneously
so the world that we inhabit
given that we're alive
and given that what's selected as
selected us to act is actually a
pragmatic world
and the objects of pragmatic worlds
aren't objects they're tools
and obstacles
and they have valence a priori they're
they have value a priori from the
Newtonian perspective you look at the
world
and then you think about the world that
you see the objects of the world that
you see and then you evaluate them and
then you act and that is not how your
brain works
it's just wrong
um
you might see the value of things before
you see the object itself
I mean there are people for example who
are blind they have blind sight they can
recognize emotions on faces without
knowing they can see
so
that's partly because their retinas are
attached to the remygdala
your retina is attached to a lot of your
body not just your visual cortex it's
attached to your spinal cord it's
attached to your nervous system at
multiple levels of analysis
simultaneously and so you can use your
eyes to detect things that you don't
know you're seeing
so and what in some sense what you often
detect under those circumstances is
valence value so you're very good for
example
at detecting teeth
and predatory eyes and the reasons for
that are
self-evident fundamentally
this is the smallest unit of meaning
that makes up a referential frame I
think
it has
three elements
one of which links the mind to the body
actually the Mind Body problem isn't
that difficult to solve if once you take
a pragmatic once you look at how the
brain works from a pragmatic perspective
because then your your Consciousness is
fundamentally something that's grounded
in action
and you can understand the transition
between Consciousness and action as a
sequence of of
analysis that are increasingly action
oriented I'll talk to you about that a
little bit later but the basic framework
is something like this and you're always
looking at the world through this
framework and the framework has as one
poll where you are and what you're doing
where you are now so that's point a
you're always trying to get from point A
to point B because you're a linear
creature and you're embodied so you're
moving and so fundamentally what you're
looking at the world through is a
sequence of maps and Maps tell you how
to get to where you want to go and so
the map specifies where you are because
obviously you can't get anywhere if you
don't know where you are and many people
of course are confused about where they
are so they don't get anywhere
and you also have to know where you're
going
and that's point a and point B and every
time you look at the world you're
looking through a framework that has
those two valued points implicit in your
cognitive structure
and generally what you think is
where you're going is better than where
you are
because otherwise why would you go there
now some people do choose to go to
places that are worse than where they
are but they're a special case you
probably live with some of them
now when you're going from point A to
point B
undamentally you have to move
now movement is not abstract movement is
what you do with your body
and so once your abstract representation
transforms itself into action you're no
longer in the realm of abstraction
so in order to get from one place to
another you have to know where you are
and you have to know where you're going
and then you have to walk fly run roll
you have to perform some sort of
embodied action to get there and of
course you have conscious control over
your voluntary muscular system but
underneath that you don't really have
anything at all right you can move your
arm you have no idea what muscles you're
moving so your conscious representation
of your body grounds out basically at
voluntary movement of the larger muscle
systems
so
now you might ask well what does specify
where you're going and answer to that in
large part is biology but biology in a
complex Manner and this is where higher
order morality starts to become a
concern
you share with other animals
all the way down the phylogenetic chain
various forms of of implicit motivation
and you know you can kind of lump those
it's arbitrary I lump them into
self-maintenance motivations and
self-propagation motivations you know
you could cut that in different ways
like I said it's more conceptual than
than based on say you know
Anatomy but it'll do
self-maintenance well you don't want to
get too hot you don't want to get too
cold your hypothalamus deals with that
very old part of the brain it's way more
important than your cortex
you can take the whole cortex off a
female cat and as long as you keep it in
a cage and it has its hypothalamus it
can pretty much behave like a cat except
that it's hyper exploratory which is the
last thing you'd expect from an animal
with no brain
you can't be too hot you can't be too
cold you got to regulate your water
intake you have to eat
you have to deal with the consequences
of eating you have to be with other
people there's a play circuit A
specialized play circuit there's a
specialized erotic circuit
there's a specialized circuit for
exploration which is about half of what
the hypothalamus does by the way
um
and those those systems they've often
been conceptualized as drives but
they're not really that they're more
like
isolated one-eyed personalities
they're like Cyclops they want one thing
now they're not stupid but they're not
very
amenable to argument
so when you're hungry you're hungry and
you know another motivational system
might object to that but and that
happens frequently which is partly why
people are often confused and also why
you need a cortex because you know you
need a cortex to allow the competing
motivational systems to array themselves
properly and harmoniously across time so
that they all get their due instead of
fighting like two-year-olds in a room
because two-year-olds are basically
hypothalamic you know and so they're
lots of fun but they're not organized
and they're not social at all
so what happens with the motivational
systems very deep in your brain is they
they specify the value of where you are
so that one of the values might be I'm
thirsty
and then they tune your perception so
that things that are associated with the
quenching of thirst are much more likely
to be picked up by your perceptual
system and they bias your
perceptual processing and your valuation
towards the
towards Improvement of that motivational
lack
and and so you can't really think of
them as drives because they're way more
complicated than that they specify where
you are so there's a element of
self-consciousness that's associated
with that I'm thirsty
and they specify a Target usually using
fantasy you know you get thirsty you
think well what would I like to drink
and eat a little fantasy about maybe a
glass of juice or a bit of water or
something like that and then your
nervous system is tuned and then you
walk into the kitchen and you ignore
everything that's irrelevant to the
search for liquid and you focus in on
everything that's relevant to the search
for liquid and that means you're so
blind you cannot believe it I mean
there's been many experiments now that
have shown that
you can do things like I'm sure some of
you have seen this you can introduce a
gorilla into a basketball game and 60 or
70 percent of the people watching as
long as they're paying attention to the
ball they won't see the gorilla and it's
not like a little tiny gorilla that's
somewhere off in the corner it's like
main center six feet high beating its
chest and even when you know that if
something else changes in the background
you won't see that either so as far as
you guys know that
carpet could be changing colors 15 20
times a minute you wouldn't even notice
it unless you had some weird obsession
with carpets
so
okay so that's the beginning in some
sense of a universal system of values
right and I can tell you how Universal
this is I always have to tell this story
because it's so damn funny I just can't
believe it so
one of the things that your brain is
very concerned with is relative status
that's wired in by the way which is
partly why relative poverty is often
such a social problem people hate being
low in status
especially men well the male status
hierarchy is a bit different than women
and women are pretty sensitive to status
too but they use different markers
anyways
part what happens when your status goes
up is your brain serotonin levels go up
and when your brain serotonin levels go
up
you're less irritable and and you've
experience less negative emotion per
unit of uncertainty or threat and so
when you you know when you demean
someone and you interfere with
and you lower the their presumed status
as far as a very primordial circuit is
concerned you alter the system that
regulates their emotions and they hate
that
people hate that more than anything and
it's an unbelievably archaic circuit you
can kind of tell this because depressed
people basically act like they're low
status and depressed people are
depressed about everything now it's not
easy to be depressed about everything
right and so the fact that that's the
case means that what's ever going astray
has to be very primordial because it
affects everything
anyways people often use antidepressants
to cure depression
hence their name
an antidepressants
decrease the rate at which serotonin is
taken back up by the neurons that
produce it
well
300 million years ago Crustaceans
emerged and Crustaceans live in
dominance hierarchies
even though they're not particularly
social
and if one Lobster fights with another
and gets defeated then he won't fight
with another Lobster even when he beat
for 20 minutes
unless you give them antidepressants
in which case he'll fight again right
away the reason I'm telling you this is
because
the status structure that
underlies your being not just your brain
but your being is
is so old you share it with crustaceans
so you mess with it at your peril
it's not learned
by no means
so anyways you you wander around inside
one of these little frames going from
point A to point B all the time and one
of the annoying things about life and
this is sort of the Sisyphus story is
that as soon as you climb from point A
to point B and you get there then
there's another point a and another
point B and that's kind of interesting
too because one of the things that
suggests is that
getting somewhere isn't really what
people want because as soon as you get
somewhere then you're done going there
and then you have to get somewhere else
so in some sense it seems it's an
accomplishment another sense it's just
the next Rock up the mountain now you
all know this because you know you
graduated from University and that was a
good day but the next day you weren't a
university student you were some
unemployed loser you know and so and
that's you know that sets up a whole new
set of problems right and I mean that's
how the frame shifts and when the frame
shifts like that then the value of
everything shifts around it
so
turns out that people are actually more
interested in getting from point A to
point B than they are in actually being
at point B and almost all of the
positive emotion that you feel which is
related to dopaminergic circuitry by the
way you experience in relationship to
the pursuit of a valued goal rather than
to the attainment of the goal the
attainment of the goal actually
satisfies you or more specifically it
satisfies that motivational circuit but
then the damn thing just shuts off and
another one starts yelling at you so
it's like a perverse form of Victory so
one answer to that that's Universal in
some sense is that you should establish
a relationship with a Transcendent value
because it never runs out of
motivational power
you can see an example of that's popular
example in popular culture in the
Pinocchio movie which I'm how many of
you have seen that
yeah is anybody not seen it
that's amazing anyways
um in the Pinocchio movie one of the
things that happens is when Geppetto
wishes that his son becomes a full
developed individual instead of a damn
puppet which is a good thing for a
parent to Wish by the way he wishes upon
a star and the star signifies something
of transcendent value and so the meaning
of that fundamentally is that if you
want to raise your child to be an
independent being then you better set
your sights on something transcended or
it won't happen and believe me there's
lots of times it doesn't happen
so
part of the utility of a Transcendent
value is that never loses its
motivational Effectiveness now you might
say well that's no proof that there are
Transcendent values it's like yeah
that's true but you know there's more to
the story
Okay so
when you're in one of these little
stories which is basically what they are
they're the simplest story I was one
place I went by this means to another
place that's the simplest story it's not
that exciting much more exciting story
as I was going from point A to B and
something weird happened and then I
didn't know where I was and then I was
like in chaos for you know two years and
then I figured out how to climb out of
it everybody likes that story right
that's a death and rebirth Story by the
way or a fall from Paradise story with a
regaining of paradise at the end you
know it's an archetypal story because
everyone lives it and so
anyways when you're in one of these
little
stories frames of reference what you see
in front of you are really things that
one of the best scientists who ever
studied visual perception
called
the book's called ecological approach to
visual perception
he called them affordances
an affordance is something that affords
you something and affordances can be
positive or negative I like to think
about them as tools or obstacles so for
example if I need to make a beeline for
that door you guys are all instantly
obstacles and the way I would respond to
that like implicitly is that you'd all
be negative so imagine we just said fire
well you were people the minute before
that but you know the second after that
your obstacles and your emotional
reactions to the people that are in
front of you are going to reflect that
now you all know that because you drive
you know and once you're encapsulated in
your little insectoid shell and don't
have to deal with the immediate
responses of other people you're going
to treat them like obstacles and like
you know demonic obstacles at the drop
of a hat and you know that's pretty much
automatic Behavior so tools are things
that get you to where you want to go and
you remember you know human beings are
tool using animals par Excellence right
we're so tool using that that's what we
see it's built right into us we're
always scanning the world for tools when
you look at gravel for example what you
actually see are throwing sized rocks
that's why they manifest themselves as
that kind of object in the environment
you know you're built at a certain level
of resolution and the way your nervous
system parts parses up the world is into
things that are useful for you and
things that aren't and those are not
objects
the whole idea of object is a very very
modern derivative of that much more
primordial system and it's by no means
clear at all that our notion of object
is more real than the notion of
affordance in fact as far as your brain
is concerned objects
no one cares about objects what your
brain cares about is affordances and
what your brain is adapted to is the
world has a set of affordances as
obstacles and if you're a darwinian it's
very difficult to escape the conclusion
that what selected you
is reality and so if the reality that
selected you shaped you so that what you
see are affordances and obstacles or you
die
then it's perfectly real proposition
perfectly reasonable proposition to
state that what reality is in fact is a
set of affordances
tools and obstacles and that is how your
brain works by the way when you look at
say I look at that projector maybe I'm
thinking about picking it up what
happens is my eyes activate the part of
my motor cortex that would adjust my
hand to grip it like that and so part of
what I understand as the projector is
grippable object
and that's not a secondary derivation I
don't see the object and then think this
is how I would grip it it's like that
would take forever
you know you'd never catch a baseball if
that's what you were doing it's like oh
a round object is clunk you know it's
like that's just not gonna work you're
not really your nervous system is
nowhere fast enough to do that
consciously you're using reptile
circuitry to catch baseballs the
mammalian stuff is too damn slow so you
catch the ball often especially if
someone pitches it fast before you can
even see it you just think you saw it
you see it after you caught it
the case with tennis players too they
what they seem to do is Judge where the
ball is going to go by the angle of the
racket because if they wait till the
ball is off the racket they can't move
fast enough to hit it back they don't
have the reflexes for it so they can't
move the neural messages fast enough to
do it
okay so basically the world lays itself
out as tools and obstacles and you know
obstacles make you feel bad but like
let's say I'm looking at this room and
I'm thinking to you guys as obstacles
you might say well how bad does that
make me feel and the answer to that is
well not very bad because all I have to
do is you know make a circuitous route
and I can get to the door so then the
fact that your obstacles is a very minor
impediment to the execution of my plan
and as a consequence it will produce a
correspondingly low level of negative
emotion
so you can think of those as known
unknowns in rumsfeld's terms no one
unknowns aren't that big a problem
because you can plan for them and you
might have a plan that's an alternative
plan that you could put in place in case
they show up
what people really don't like are
unknown unknowns and unknown unknowns
you don't walk around those man they
blow your whole map and your map's quite
complicated it's actually hierarchical
in structure and I'll get to that
because you know you go from point A to
point B so that you can go to a bigger
point A to point B you know
you cross the road to get to the library
to study for an exam to pass the exam to
get your degree to get a job to be a
person to be a citizen to be a you know
to have a good life so then if someone
gets in your way while you're crossing
the road then to some degree they're
interfering with you getting a good life
no not very much but sometimes you'll
react like that that certainly happens
when you're dealing with an intimate
partner you know because they'll make
some little mistake and you'll say
um you always do that you're always
going you've always done that you always
do it and you're always going to do it
which is really not a good way to
conduct an argument
yeah
so
unknown unknowns well I'm not an unknown
unknowns leap at you from places that
you wouldn't expect
because otherwise you would have planned
for the damn things so they're the
things that are always like poking their
beak up at you when you least expect it
they're just like say serpents in the
Garden of Eden that might be one way of
thinking about it you can't keep the
damn snakes out of the garden
and that's because you can't make a
bounded area and keep the complexity out
of it the complexity always sneaks back
in try protecting your children from the
internet for example
you can't make a bounded circumstance
and get rid of all the complexity it
always comes sneaking back in so what
would be an unknown unknown this is a
good one here you have an intimate
relationship you've had it for 10 years
you trust your partner so what does that
mean you know where you are
You Know Who You Are
and you have a pretty good idea of who
of where you're going
and then one day you'll find out that
your partner has been cheating on you
not with one person but with three
people and for the whole 10 years
well hypothetically that comes as a
shock although you may have ignored many
intimations that such might be the case
irrelevant let's say it comes as a shark
well what happens to you
while you don't know where you are
you don't know where you've been that's
interesting eh because you think you
know where you've been because you've
already been there but all of a sudden
something can happen so that you are so
flipped over that you don't even know
where you were
so that means in some sense the past is
dependent on the present a very peculiar
thing you also have no idea where you're
going
in terms of not knowing where you are
that's deep eh because you might think
well I you know I thought it was in a
marriage that turns out to be wrong I
thought I knew who my wife or husband
was that turns out to be wrong
I concluded on the basis that I knew my
wife that I knew something about women
that turned out to be wrong
I thought I was in a relationship with
someone I could trust that is wrong I
don't know enough about trust I'm
obviously too gullible and so what that
does is throw virtually everything
that's ever happened to me in severe
doubt right that's the emergence of
Chaos
and that's
this sometimes
you're going from point A to point B and
something you don't expect manifests
itself in the middle of your plan but
it's not such a catastrophe because you
can just work around it and then
sometimes something pops up and like you
just do not have a plan anymore and so
then you might ask yourself just exactly
where you are you when you don't know
where you are
and I would say that's a place and it's
actually a place that's well documented
in
classic religious and mythological
stories that's chaos the Taoist for
example they believe that the world is
made out of Chaos and Order
well order that's where you are when
what you do gets you what you want
chaos
that's where you are when you have no
idea what's going on and you might ask
well is there a way that you should act
when you're in chaos and the answer to
that is there better be
because it's a place you're going to
visit several times during your life and
everyone visits that
that's why it's an archetypal Story
That's The Descent to the underground
the underground is that horrible place
that lurks underneath all of our
presuppositions it's the
frigid Lake underneath the thin ice that
everybody's skating on and it's
something that can manifest itself at
any moment that's partly why in the
Taoist symbol the black Paisley is chaos
by the way and the white paisley is
ordered in the order Paisley there's a
little black dot well that's because
order can turn into chaos and does at
any moment
and the reverse is also true chaos can
turn into order at any moment and
insight will do that for you you know
alcoholics report that when they hit
bottom it's like there's a catalysis and
they look at the world in a different
way you know now they're a new person
they're back from the underground
they've risen from the dead so to speak
you know and it's partly because what
looks like your right hemisphere is
pretty good at
inferring patterns in in novel and
chaotic places it's kind of keeping
track of things that happen to you that
are anomalous and it makes alternative
maps of the world that are there for you
to rely on at least to some degree if
that ever becomes necessary
now you might ask yourself
how upset should you be when something
that you don't expect happens now it
turns out that that is really a
difficult question to answer because
what the problem is is that when
something you don't expect happens you
don't know what it is and so then you
might say well how upset should you get
and the answer to that is
you don't know
and so what happens is first of all
you've got some built-in approximators
one would be your
genetically determined level of
neuroticism which is basically
sensitivity to negative emotion if
you're more sensitive to negative
emotion you're going to manifest more
psychophysiological preparation per unit
of threat or uncertainty which is to say
some people get more upset about the
same thing than other people do now
who's right well if you
who knows you wake up in the morning and
there's a little ache in your side it's
like well what is that is sore muscle or
cancer you don't know and if you're
hypochondriacal well it's going to be
cancer and sometimes the hypochondriac
is right and so he's the one that lives
when he goes to the emergency room and
finds out exactly what's going on so
it's an unanswerable question now the
other way that your brain determines how
upset you should be is by calculating
your position in the dominance hierarchy
because the higher you are in the
dominance hierarchy the more resources
you have at your disposal and so the
less upset you have to get when anything
horrible happens so if you're barely
clinging to the bottom of the social
structure you can be sure that your
brain is going to estimate any anomalous
occurrence as a catastrophe which is why
people don't like being at the bottom of
the dominance hierarchy and it's also
why people who are there die a lot
sooner
and they do they die a lot sooner
regardless of their absolute level of
wealth it's relative deprivation that
counts okay so here's a bit of a clue
about how else your brain might
calculate how upset you should be
here's a little map of me when I'm doing
something that I frequently do which is
to write a manuscript so you might say
well what are you doing when you're
writing a manuscript and that turns out
to be a very complicated question it's
like what are you doing when you read
read a book well
you're writing letters or typing them
you're typing words you're typing
phrases you're typing sentences you're
typing paragraphs you're typing the
structure that the paragraphs fit into
that would be the essay
okay then your
me anyways I'm practicing science
because I usually write scientific
manuscripts and that's part of embodying
my professorial role and then that's
part of hypothetically being a
productive citizen although some of you
might you know differ with that given
that I'm a professor and then perhaps on
the outside of that or this is what I
think is on the outside of that is I'm
confronting the unknown
and you might say well
what are you really doing when you're
writing a sentence and the answer to
that is you're doing all of these things
better or worse and if you're doing a
really good job of writing a sentence
you're doing all of them at once and
that would be one of the things that
would make the sentence particularly
meaningful now
if something anomalous occurs well let's
say the T on my typewriter gets stuck
well that's going to irritate me because
then I can't type a sentence now it's
not going to irritate me too much
because you know it doesn't really
interfere with my ability to be a
productive citizen
so I'm going to
estimate the magnitude of how upset I
should be when something unknown occurs
by estimating where in the hierarchy
of action that anomaly
is disruptive okay so let me run you
through this again so let's say
um
what's a good person and you might think
of that from an objective perspective
but that would be a mistake because uh
quality like good is a pragmatic quality
and it's based on action not on object
so here's how you decompose being a good
person
so
a good person is a good parent more than
that that's a sub component right a good
parent is someone who has a job and
takes care of their family and then a
person who takes care of their family is
like they can play with the baby or they
can complete a meal these are abstract
Concepts you can't tell a four-year-old
make a meal and the reason you can't is
because they don't know the subordinate
components of making a meal you can say
see that fork
hopefully they know what a fork is see
that fork yes
pick up that fork and bring that fork to
the table and put it there they can do
that because their nervous system is
organized enough to operate at that
level of abstraction but they can't do
something like make a meal which is you
know if you got a three-year-old you
can't put them in their room and you say
clean up your room they'll just look at
you and then when they come back when
you come back in half an hour they'll
look at you again you can say Hey kid
see that teddy bear yeah pick up the
teddy bear and put it on that space in
the wall and then once you teach the
three-year-old how to do a hundred of
those things and they got it they've got
a little motor routines you can say
clean the room you can encapsulate that
entire set of motor routines within the
higher order concept so if you're being
a good person part of that is well maybe
you're making a meal and part of that
would be well you're cutting up the
vegetables but then things get
interesting because when you're cutting
up the vegetables what you're actually
doing is gripping something and moving
and then that's no longer abstract right
that's where your conceptual
philosophical presuppositions like be a
good person hit the hit the hit the
level of embodied material reality
that's the dissolution of the Mind into
the body
now
if someone says to you you should cut
those vegetables more thinly
that might irritate you but if they say
you're a bad parent maybe observing the
same phenomena then you're going to get
into a fight with them
and so and the reason for that is
obviously if it's just a matter of
cutting the vegetables thinner all you
have to do is make a minor modification
in the hierarchy that constitutes
yourself
representation or really yourself it's
not just a representation but if you're
not a good parent it's like
if that's true you got a lot of you got
a lot of repair work to do a lot of your
world is falling apart
and as soon as Things Fall Apart which
they always do you're in chaos and as
soon as you're in chaos then your body
defaults to emergency preparation and
you're stressed and if you're stressed
long enough then you die
and so you don't like that stress say
when your body gets stressed what
happens is because it doesn't really
know what's going on It prepares for
everything that's the generalized stress
response cortisol production does that
cortisol production is good it wakes you
up in the morning but if it's chronic
you get old
like it's so
General in its negative
actions that the best way to
conceptualize its detrimental long-term
effect is that it accelerates aging so
it makes you more likely to have heart
disease and cancer and depression and
Alzheimer's and
diabetes and obesity
that'll do
it's enough
any of those are enough to kill you
all right so there's a hierarchy that's
a hierarchy of values
the higher the value the more the less
you want to have it disrupted now
there's a psychologist named Piaget
some of you might know about him
Piaget was very interested in
what happens to Value structures and
their hierarchical organization once
they have to apply outside of the
confines of a body so so here's a way of
thinking about it two-year-olds
basically hypothalamic that's why
they're so much fun first they're happy
then they're sad then they're hungry
then they're tired you know they just
zip from one pretty straightforward and
rather awe-inspiring motivational state
to another and but at two they can't
play
they can play with by themselves
but they can't play with other children
they can't get that until they're three
and they need to get it by the time
they're three because if they don't get
it by the time they're four they will
never get it and then you have an
anti-social kid who's going to be an
outsider for his entire life and there
isn't anything you can do about it so
that has to happen between two and four
so what happens at about age three is
that the kid learns how to play a game
with another person and what that game
is is fundamentally the development of
the ability to share a frame of
reference which is what you're doing
when you play Monopoly it's like it's
stupid to play Monopoly obviously who
cares if you have a whole pile of
counterfeit paper right but doesn't
matter a because the way you're
constituted is that your brain will
treat anything you act like constitutes
a valuable goal as if it's a valid
framework of reference and if it
couldn't do that a you couldn't abstract
and B you could not get along with other
people so you can sit around the table
and you can say let's pretend that
Monopoly is a reasonable facsimile of
reality which you wouldn't say but it's
what you mean and everybody says yes
that would be amusing and so then you
set your goal which is to get all the
little hotels and all the money and poof
your emotions go along for the ride and
what's so interesting about that is you
can get everybody into the game and so
one of the things that's really
interesting about people is that we can
establish a shared fictional frame of
reference and it organizes all our
emotions so they're predictable that's
also why we can watch movies
you go to a movie you identify the hero
you figure out what the hero wants poof
you're the hero and the way that works
is you don't look at the hero and think
about what he's doing and evaluate it
emotionally and then feel it what you do
is you specify the hero's goal and then
you map him onto your body and you read
off the emotional responses of your own
body and that's how you understand the
hero
so it's it's embodied you're you're
using your your embodiment as a
computational device that can run
simulations of other consciousnesses and
it does that with the body and we like
doing that you can go to a movie and you
know your Brad Pitt for an hour and a
half
you know when you're Brad Pitt doing
remarkable things and that's also how we
understand other people
we're very good at that so anyways we
have these shared frames of reference
like when we're playing Monopoly okay so
children at three learn how to play
games and that means they learn how to
organize their own internal motivational
States into a hierarchy that includes
the motivational states of other people
and that means they can play and that's
what you guys do when you're out in the
world like we're playing a game right
now we all know the rules that's why we
can all sit in this room and play the
game without fighting with each other
you know when the room is set up like a
theater and we all know the theater game
and so and the chairs are always facing
this way at the moment and so that's a
hint that you should look forward and
this is raised so you know the room is
basically telling you what to do because
it's a stage like all rooms and because
you're smart and socially conscious you
can walk into a staged room and your
body knows what to do and if you're
civilized and social you just do it then
all the other primates can predict what
you're up to and they won't kill you
yeah well that's what it means to be
part of the same tribe you know when
people are very peculiar creatures and
God only knows what they're up to but as
long as they're playing the same game
you are you don't have to know what
they're up to because you can predict
what they're going to do and you
understand their motivational States
and so part of the building and
constructing of higher order motive
higher order
moral
goals is the establishment of joint
frames of reference that allow multiple
people to pursue the goals that they're
interested in simultaneously and then
what you have to think about with
regards to that is that not all shared
frames of reference can manage that
there's a small subset of them that are
optimized so that not only can multiple
people play them but multiple people can
play them and enjoy them and do it
repeatedly across a long period of time
so it's iterate ability that partly
defines the utility of a higher order
moral structure and that is not
arbitrary
it's an emergent property of biological
interactions and you might say well it's
kind of arbitrary because people can do
what they want but it's not arbitrary at
all because a lot of what's constraining
your games is your motivational
substructure and those ancient circuits
that are status oriented and they
operate Within
virtually every animal has a status
counter creatures organize themselves
into dominance hierarchies the reason
they do that is because that works
it's a solution it's a solution to the
darwinian problem of existence it's not
just an epith phenomena it's the real
thing so you your environment
fundamentally a huge chunk of your
environment is dominance hierarchy plus
God only knows where you are and that's
Order and Chaos and part of the reason
that people fight to preserve their
dominance hierarchies is because it's
better to be a slave who knows what the
hell is going on than someone who's
thrown screaming and naked into the
jungle at night and that's the
difference between Order and Chaos and
we like order better than chaos and it's
no wonder now we'll invite a little
chaos in for entertainment now and then
but has to be done voluntarily and
generally you don't want the kind of
chaos that upsets your entire conceptual
structure you know you're willing to
fool around on the fringes a little bit
but you know when the going gets serious
you're pretty much likely to bail out
and no wonder
now I want to tell you a little bit
about
this chaotic domain I can tell you a
couple of things about it
it's the underworld of Mythology
one of the things that's kind of
interesting about the underworld is that
has a suburb and one of the suburbs of
the underworld is hell
and hell is the place where you end up
when
everything that you know falls apart
and you get resentful and bitter about
it and that's very like one of the
things I've noticed in my work as a
clinical psychologist that there's two
things that really do people in three
lying that's not good apart from that
resentment
and arrogance if you get resentful
enough
you end up like Elliot Rogers and all
those other people who go on random
shooting sprees because they have a
disagreement about the structure of the
exist of existence and the fact that
they ended up hypothetically at the
bottom of the Heap
so those are real places and people get
stuck in them and they are not places
that you would
voluntarily choose to go if you had any
sense at all and I'll tell you if you
read the accounts of the people who do
random mass murder they'll tell you
exactly where they are and they'll tell
you exactly what they're motivated to do
and what they're motivated to do is take
as much revenge on existence as they
possibly can imagine in the most unfair
possible way as fast as they can
possibly manage it
and that's their conscious aim and it is
not a form of insanity they know exactly
what they're doing they have it they
have a precise idea of what they're
aiming at and it's a deep archetypal
possession for lack of a better word
now
I want to show you how some of these
things are mapped
symbolically
they're not really symbols in my
estimation because a symbol implies
that something is being
represented you know that there's a
reality behind the representation that's
broader than the representation the
symbol is just a shadow of it these
aren't symbols they're representations
that are as accurate as they can
possibly be
I'll start with something that's rather
easy to understand
let's try
where is that
yes
what happens when you look at the Medusa
you turn to Stone what happens when a
rabbit sees a wolf
that's right it turns to Stone that's
right the Medusa
is a symbol it's a representation
of all those things that make you turn
to Stone when you look at them now look
animals can deal with threat right they
have instincts to deal with threat
but zebras maybe there's a bunch of
zebras and they're out there in a herd
and there's a bunch of lions and they're
right there and the zebras what are they
doing they're grazing and you think well
those zebras aren't very bright because
there's a bunch of lions like why aren't
they you know in the forest building a
fort to keep the Lions out but they they
reason they're not doing that is because
although they can react to threat they
cannot conceive to the of the class of
threatening objects
now human beings can conceive of the
class of threatening objects and so what
civilization is in a large part is an
attempt to find a remedy for the class
of threatening objects now there are
representations of those sorts of things
the Medusa is one of them the reason
it's feminine is very difficult to
explain and I don't think I have the
time unfortunately but you'll have to
take my word for it you see the little
cartoon of Robert Crum off to the left
there he's got a big eatable problem old
Rob Crum and the problem with him
fundamentally is his mother was
something like a giant spider and did
everything she possibly could to crush
the life out of him hence his remaining
relationship with women and so that's
part of the reason why femininity can be
a
something that turns you to Stone it's
an experience that many men are familiar
with by the way because the average man
is rejected far more often than he's
accepted and since women are the gateway
to reproduction they constitute nature
itself and nature itself tells most men
you should go home and stay under your
bed
there's lots of experiments done about
this so for example psychologists have
an undergraduate woman go out into the
Concourse and see how long it takes
someone her to find someone who agrees
to sleep with her and that takes like
you know
two seconds after she asks the first man
and then
and then they flip it you know and they
get your random undergraduate guy to do
the same thing it's well you can imagine
the consequences of that since many of
you men have lived through it
Mother Nature
with a woman wears the face of Mother
Nature and the face is generally
rejecting especially to men who are low
in the dominance hierarchy by the way
which is one of the things that
irritates guys like Elliot Rogers and
one of the things that motivates their
desire to take revenge that's a
universal phenomena
so that's part of the reason that the
feminine is nature and why Nature by the
way is Mother Nature it's like it's
diagnosis of your status is not good
enough and no wonder
what seems to have happened
fundamentally
is that these domains that I talk to you
about which can be represented as Chaos
and Order say an R from the Taoist
perspective can also be represented as
masculine and feminine
and I think the reason for that is that
human beings are fundamentally social
primates right we're very very social
and we know that one of the correlates
of brain size in primates is social
group size and we also know that most
primates say chimps who were quite
closely related to they don't like go
out and investigate leaves and you know
parent things through microscopes they
spend all their time interacting with
other chimpanzees although they're
chewing all the time they do it because
they have a ridiculously ineffective you
know Digestive and eating system
um
their brain is
adapted
to the social circumstances as the
primary reality so you could say well
tribe is the primary reality and then
there's a secondary reality which is all
that which is outside tribe and that
corresponds to chaos in order
order in contradiction to chaos is
symbolized by masculine symbols and
that's for example why ideologies like
radical feminism presume the existence
of a patriarchy it fits into the
symbolic structure of our minds that
idea and it's true in some sense because
just like in chimpanzee troops the
primary or meta hierarchy that makes up
human civilization is fundamentally
masculine in its origin and structure
and so masculine is fundamentally the
dominance hierarchy and feminine is some
fundamentally all the things that are
outside or that challenge the dominance
hierarchy and so it's and it's a
perfectly reason it's weird eh because
our brain is organized to
fundamentally apprehend the world in
terms of personalities and that's partly
because you know as we've emerged over
the course of evolution it's been
relatively constant that there were
males around and that there were females
around and that the males were fathers
and that the females were mothers and
you know that they were both mates as
well it's a constant of The evolutionary
landscape and that's what our brains
evolve to process and then what happened
when we developed the capacity to
abstract is we use this underlying
social cognitive
abstraction structure to start to
represent the structure of being itself
so we could say well there's a dominance
hierarchy in that society and that's
masculine and there's all the things
that challenge the dominance hierarchy
and they're outside and they're feminine
the weirdest thing about that however is
that it actually works
you know we've gone away with that for
some reason it seems to be perfectly
reasonable to map the world in that
manner it keeps us going
all right I'm going to try to explain
this this is now chemical symbol
at the bottom of the symbol there's this
round thing with wings
do you ever see Harry Potter
yeah you know the game Quidditch
you remember what they chase
they chase a gold one of those
all right so they call that the snitch I
believe and there's a little fragment of
soul and it's very interesting idea
because for the Alchemists the primary
element of reality whatever that was
could be conceptualized as this thing
this round chaos and what it was
conceptualized of in part was
it was a container from which matter and
spirit could emerge and you might ask
well what does that mean
this is what it means
when a child experiences something it
can't predict
it does the thing that led to that
uncertain outcome over and over and over
and over until it can map it and then
you think well what did the child do
what the child did was take the domain
of that which it did not understand
and it transformed it into matter which
is the predictable world of entities and
spirit which is the internal
psychological structure that's adapted
to that and so what the Alchemists
basically conceptualized was that
what exists outside of your conceptual
framework is something like
unrealized potential and when you
interact with that unrealized potential
you actualize it and you actualize it
into two component elements one being
the material world and the other being
your own psychological structure that's
why they conceptualized matter and
spirit the container of matter and
spirit as the Ultimate Reality and out
of that emerged something that was quite
primordial which is the Dragon
now
one of the things we know
remember in the Genesis story
it's the snake that gives people Vision
remember that
it gives them wisdom and it also
produces self-consciousness
there's a woman named Lynn Isbell who's
an anthropologist in LA and she was very
interested in human being's sight
because we can really see we can see
better than any other creature except
predatory Birds we can see way better
than most primates
Isabel knew that our tree dwelling
ancestors some 60 million years ago
emerged at about the same time as snakes
they're younger than lizards by the way
and that we were preyed on quite
intensely by snakes for tens of millions
of years she also knew that we were good
at detecting snakes in the bottom of our
visual field and then we were
particularly good at detecting the
camouflage patterns of snakes in the
bottom of our visual field so she did a
series of field experiments showing that
primate visual Acuity was correlated
strongly with the presence of predatory
snakes in the immediate environment
so the idea that snakes gave us vision
is right now why is that relevant to
this
we were preyed upon for a very long
period of time and we developed a neural
circuit to deal with predators and
that's the neural circuit that's
activated in children when they're
terrified about monsters at night
so the Predator entity which is this
Dragon it's like a it's like an amalgam
of predatory forces
is one of the manifestations of the
things that exist outside of the
dominance heart so it's a it's a form of
primordial reality it's not abstract
anymore like the matter and spirit
container it's like the first practical
manifestation of what's terrifying and
threatening concretely outside that and
so remember
animals can respond to threat but they
can't conceptualize threat as a category
that's the conceptualization of threat
as a category it emerges from the
absolute unknown it manifests itself as
threat so for example if you hear a loud
noise behind you or a growl when you're
in the forest the first thing that
happens is you don't know what's going
on and that's the initial state of
contact with potential and then if you
turn around and you look that potential
manifests itself into something that's
predatory and you have a circuit for
that and that's the same circuit that we
now use to assess anything unexpected
that occurs to us and that circuit had
to come from somewhere and so our
capacity to respond to surprising
entities is an elaboration an
elaboration up into abstraction of our
capacity to identify Predators so that's
the next level of reality and out of
that
chaotic circumstance comes something
that's more human and that that is the
emergence of masculinity and femininity
out of that more primordial element
let me show you
two things
this is a map of
pragmatic territory as far as I can tell
it's the territory that people actually
inhabit
at the first level it's the square I
called that the dragon of Chaos
that's the unknown as such
and it's the thing that you fall into
with your conceptual schemes Fall Apart
what manifests itself out of that is
femininity and femininity comes in two
forms one is benevolent femininity
example would be
this
you see Mary on the left there she's in
a structure called a mandorla which is
from a Freudian perspective has obvious
sexual connotations you see if you look
carefully that she's standing on a
reptile and holding her child away from
it
it's a common medieval Christian image
and you can think of it as Divine
because women spent an awful lot of time
doing that with their children over the
course of our millions of years of
evolution and it's something that's
sacred because our species depended on
that for its for its survival this one's
even better this is a medieval image I
love this image so there's Mary with the
Christ child and she's standing again on
a reptile a predatory reptile but in the
background you see all those weird
little shapes
those are musical instruments
and that they fill space and the
medieval artist who drew this picture
had this intimation that
behind the manifestation of something as
primary as
the protective maternality of Mary was
something like the music of the spears
or or a collection of harmonious
patterns and that this figure was
constantly emerging out of that
background of harmonious patterns across
the infinite stretches of time itself
that's that's a sacred image because it
represents something that Human Society
cannot live without
it's like any society that doesn't
regard
the Virgin and the child who protects
the child from the predatory serpent has
a prime element of sacred reality is
going to make itself extinct you know I
could say for example that that's what's
happening to the indigenous populations
of Eastern Europe at the moment where
their birth rate is far below
replacement
I'm going to show you another image
this is called a virge uvrant or an open
virgin and it was a common
representation in medieval Europe and
it's a weird representation from a
Christian perspective because it kind of
reverses the normal hierarchy of power
what you have here is
Mary she's holding the Christ child when
the statue is closed and then you open
her out
so what you see inside Mary is God the
Father
and God the father is holding Christ in
his hands now
Mary constitutes the superordinate
benevolent feminine and inside her is
the structure of culture so you can
think inside nature is the structure of
culture and that's represented in this
image by God
because he's the ultimate father
obviously in Christian thinking and then
the god figure is holding what crucified
individual what does that mean
now all the people around there kings
queens commoners are all gazing at that
central figure which of course is
fundamentally what everyone in western
civilization has been doing for 2000
years
not knowing why
nature gives rise to culture culture
gives rise
to the suffering individual
well that's true enough
it's true for everyone it's true for
life at every point in time
but there's more to the image of the
crucifixion because the crucifixion also
represents
voluntary acceptance of suffering
and voluntary acceptance of death and it
also points to something else that's of
Paramount importance which is that
there's an element of the human psyche
that can die and come back and die and
come back and that's what happens to you
when you encounter a catastrophe and you
make order of it and you climb back out
of the underworld and your your voids
through life is punctuated by trips to
the underworld and so you're somewhere
and then you go outside that and then
you go somewhere else and then you go
outside that and so what happens to
people is they generally identify with
where they are order
but order dissolves and collapses and
that reconstitutes itself so then you
might say if you are trying to adapt to
the structure of reality itself
instead of identifying with order
you would identify with a process that
allowed you to transform yourself across
repeated bouts of Order and Chaos
and that's what these sorts of images
are trying to represent so
let me show you
one final idea
there's a Taoist idea that's like this
so the Taoist symbol you know the Taoist
symbol I already talked to you about it
you've all seen it chaos in order
masculine and feminine
constantly
in interplay that's Dao from the Taoist
perspective and Dao is the source of
meaning so the idea there is that it's
the constant interplay between Chaos and
Order that produces the sense of meaning
in human beings and that's true
that is what produces the sense of
meaning you know that because when
you're engaged in a compelling operation
you're partly ordered and secure and you
have one foot out into the unknown and
the balance is proper and as a
consequence you're engaged in what
you're doing and as a consequence of
that you lose your self-consciousness
and if you stay engaged in that sort of
situation on a continual basis then that
you find that your life is Meaningful
and Rich and that's the best antidote to
the fact that life is bounded and full
of suffering now Dao means meaning it
also means Journey
and the center of the Dao is the place
you're supposed to be one foot in chaos
and one foot in order and that's the
best place to be in the actual
environment itself Because the actual
environment is better construed as the
constant interplay between Chaos and
Order than it is construed as a
collection of material objects
and if you adopt the pragmatic view that
points out that there are meta realities
above the mere objects that we perceive
you can also apprehend that our brains
are actually adapted to the meta
realities and not the realities because
our brains are like 300 million years
old and what we've done is abstracted
out those things that are constant
across spans of times spans of time that
are hundreds of millions of years in
length and those aren't chairs and
tables or automobiles they're they're
meta structures that are much more
sophisticated than that and we ignore
that at our Peril because modern people
don't believe that meaning exists they
think it's epiphenomenal there's nothing
subjective about our worldview when in
fact our nervous systems are tuned so
that life is manifesting itself in the
most meaningful possible way when you
happen to be occupying the precise
position between Chaos and Order that
maximizes your security and the
development of that security across time
and that's not that's the most real
thing there is and to stay in that
position is also to accept
voluntarily the necessity for a certain
degree of suffering because as you
extend your capacities by exposing
yourself to the optimal level of the
unknown you're constantly taking
yourself apart and rebuilding yourself
and that's what allows you to thrive not
only in the presence of stability but
also in a state that consists of the
transformation of that stability
here's a representation from ancient
Egypt
these are representations of Horus
there's a lot of evidence that many of
the ideas we have about Christ are
derivatives of Egyptian ideas
most people who point that out
pointed out in a manner that's aimed at
devaluing the ideas that were derived
from Egypt
because they have an a priori motive
which is a destructive motive
as mythology progresses across the
centuries it transforms itself it
attempts to continually encapsulate
re-encapsulate the primary ideas that
the human race has managed to to produce
about the structure of reality itself
there's constances across these cultural
manifestations because the reality to
which they to which they refer is
actually reality
Horus
this is a good lesson and I'll leave you
with this Horus is the eye
the eye is not the intellect
the intellect is the thing that forces
everything into a pre-existing structure
and it crunches reality to do that it
warps it and twists it and it makes
people ideological and rigid
the eye is something completely
different the eye is the thing that pays
attention and your attention is
automatically directed to those elements
of your experiential field where the
most information is manifesting itself
that's why for example if you're talking
to someone in a bar and there's a TV
flickering you can't help but look at
the TV
the change the transformation is what
your nervous system is attuned to and
the theory is that if you're a follower
of Horus who's the eye and the Falcon
because Falcons can see and they fly
above everything else if you're a
follower of Horus you pay attention
when you pay attention you absorb
information when you observe information
you continually
transform yourself and that keeps you on
top of an ever-shifting reality doing
that is Meaningful and that's what stops
you from becoming bitter and cruel
because you know life is suffering you
know and if you don't have an antidote
to that suffering that's real
then you become resentful about the
structure of experience and then you'll
do everything you can to take revenge on
it
and we saw what happened when people did
that in the 20th century
and it would be a good thing if people
woke up and stop doing it and as far as
I can tell after fig trying to figure
this out for like 30 years the way that
you do that is by paying attention and
transforming yourself when it's
necessary and stopping the process of
identifying with what you already
believe who the hell cares what you
believe you should be attending to the
things you don't know which is a much
larger space than the things you know
and then you should be construing
yourself not as the inhabitant of a
sterile and static and already completed
structure but as the thing that lives on
the edge of that that's constantly
building and rebuilding it
and then if something happens to your
structure it's not so relevant because
that's not what you are you're the thing
that can engage in transformations of
structure by paying attention
and that's what these representations
mean
these are Renaissance pictures you know
they've elevated
The Entity that voluntarily accepts the
necessity of suffering and death so
that's represented by Christ
to the highest position in the Heavenly
hierarchy
what that idea means is that what should
constitute the Transcendent value that
sits above all other values
is your capacity to voluntarily accept
the restricted and painful conditions of
your life to face them
and as a consequence of facing them
immediately transcend them
now one of the things we know from
Clinical Psychology is that if you have
someone who's afraid
they avoid
so what do you do about that
you break down the thing they're afraid
of until you find a small unit that they
can approach
when they approach it they learn that
they can approach it and that they're
more than they thought they were and
then they can approach the next thing
and then the next thing and so you take
a woman who's got agoraphobia who can't
get in an elevator and a week later she
can and then she goes home and has the
fight with her husband that she should
have had 20 years ago and the reason for
that is that when she's exposed to the
things that she's afraid of instead of
running from them she learns that she's
the thing that can be exposed to things
she's afraid of she doesn't learn that
things aren't frightening
and learning the things she's the thing
that can be exposed to things that are
frightening makes her more than the
frightening things
and it's certainly possible that we're
more than the things that frighten us
if we weren't we wouldn't be here
we shouldn't throw these things away
before we understand them and we're in
danger of doing that now
so part of what I've been trying to do
in my lectures and my work is to point
out what our forefathers knew
to try to help modern people understand
it and to
make the case that these things that we
think of as
non-real representations are more real
than anything that we
currently
comprehend as real
the consequences of not comprehending
them
and living by them as far as I can tell
is that
things deteriorate
and they can deteriorate to a point
where everything is intolerable for
everyone
and that seems to be a sub-optimal
destination
so
thanks for the invitation